Hey everybody, it's Mike from
Orderflows, and in this video I'm going
to talk about, again, sort of one of my
favorite trade setups
in order flow that is is very easy to
see and trade. You know,
a lot of traders come to the Order Flow
Footprint and sometimes they get a
little bit scared because they see all
these numbers, right? And and you know,
people have this aversion to numbers
because they think they start seeing uh
numbers on the screen, they got to start
doing math and doing some fancy
calculations. No, you know, order flow
is not about that. What order flow
really is, you know, is just showing you
how the market traded at price, you
know, how the aggressive
traders uh sold into the bid or bought
the offer and how much. And, you know,
order flow is just data, okay? And we
know when you understand what data is,
then it makes
reading the order flow very easy. And
this is like this is so stupidly simple.
I don't understand why more traders
don't just migrate to order flow simply
because this is something that you can
see in every market every day and find
great trades from, okay? [snorts] And
this is what we call the exhaustion
print. And and what an exhaustion print
is is very light volume
trading at the edge of a bar at a swing
high or a swing low, you know, or the
high of the day or the low of the day.
And this is all ultra bonds. Now, you
know, what why I like to look for
exhaustion prints in markets like bonds,
ultra bonds, tens, ultra tens is
because, generally speaking, those
markets trade a lot of volume at price.
So,
that being said, you know, like on this
low of the day right here, we trade
three at the very low, 119.18.
Three contracts. The market is selling
off, you know, people trade 1,602 at 23,
1,530 at 20 uh 2. At uh 21 they trade
994.
At 20 they trade
um
1,261
at 19,394.
Then at the low of the day, 119.18,
three contracts trade.
Do I think traders are getting tired? I
mean, you have a nice little decline
here from 1261 to 394 to just three.
Yes, I do think traders are getting
tired of selling. Either they're running
out of
what do you want to call it? Uh
ammunition, so to speak, right? They're
they're they've got no more contracts to
sell or they're just realizing that,
hey, you know what, price is just
getting too low for us to continue to
sell.
Then what happens? You got aggressive
buying coming in right off this low.
And the market starts rallying it up. It
starts rallying from 24, gets all the
way up to 04.
Pulls back.
Same thing. Three contracts trade at 25
at this swing low, just three only.
Okay? To me that's important because,
you know, this bar trades 2,622
contracts and only trades three on this
low, just as over here trades 5,000
700 but only trades three contracts.
Okay? So, these are great potential
turning points or reversal points in the
market. Right? You see this again, this
one goes up from 30 back up to 04 again,
actually gets up to 06,
uh starting to pull back down. Um let's
see here if there's a bearish example.
Okay, I mean, here's a pullback where
you get one contract trades.
Okay?
Um
This was like right around the reopen or
a little bit after the reopen but trades
two up here at the high of the day.
Right? And we sell off down into new
lows.
Okay? Here you got this double top, 293,
comes back up, trades just one contract.
This bar trades
3,722
contracts. And again, this bar is only
got This is a four range chart, so
there's only five price levels. Only
trades one contract here
at this double top swing high
and then sells off from 26 all the way
down to 17.
Okay?
Um I think those Oh, here at this high
of the day trades five. Okay? Yeah,
fine, fair enough.
Sells off again from this high. Now,
you know, here's a two, has a little
sell off.
This Here's a two but uh it's not really
a swing high cuz it doesn't get above
this this high of the day. But this one,
okay, it's perfect example. It's it's
not infallible. There's times where it
just doesn't work out. You have the new
high of the day, starts selling off but
then it reversed back up here and
stopped you out. Okay, fine. But look,
you got this trade that's a winner. This
one's a loser. This one's a winner.
This one's a
new high, that's a loser.
Okay?
Uh where was that other one here? This
is a nice winner.
This is a winner.
This is a winner. It's a eight on the
swing low here, the low of the day.
3:00 in the morning, 3:49 in the
morning, rallies up to new highs.
Okay?
Then obviously this three here is a nice
winner. This three here is a nice
winner. And this is just ultra bonds.
You see this in regular bonds, you see
this in regular tens, ultra tens, um you
can see it in currencies, crude oil,
E-minis even.
Um
You know, so it it appears in all
markets. And again, it doesn't take
anything fancy for you to see other than
looking at the footprint, right? I have
the toolbox to show me the exhaustion
prints with an order flow ratio and a
swing filter, that's why this is
highlighted here.
Um you know, if you even were just using
the Orderflows Trader software, okay?
One thing that you could do is we do
have a a setting in there, a tool that
will easily identify it for you in case
you're looking at a lot of different
markets. Here we go under um
exhaustion print. You can set it to
whatever level you want. Um you could
show it at swing highs or swing lows,
that would be right here. If you want to
have it in moves, you would use the
momentum filter and you can set whatever
you want. Um for interest rates, I think
nine is fine, okay? And you can draw it
out as a zone until tested. Yeah, you
can see it here green and red. I'll just
make it a little bit darker so it's a
little stands out more.
And we'll just throw it up on our chart.
Like I said, I I it's not something that
every single trade is going to be an
automatic winner. I showed you a few
examples where it just it didn't work
out. But, you know, that's how it goes.
Now, if you're using the swing filter,
it's going to be related to whatever you
have up here for your swing period of
five. That's why this one is not showing
right here
um because it's not a swing low based on
the swing filter, but this one is
showing here.
Um you know, there's one here.
That's the one that failed. There's the
winner here.
It's a winner here. This one failed. So,
yeah, you can see how
it's very easy to identify, you know, if
if you even wanted to, we could adjust
the swing filter down to sort of capture
more of them, you know, it's set at
five, so that's why it's not showing a
few of those that I highlighted earlier,
but let's uh just go in and change this.
We'll just
change it to whatever lower number, I
don't know, two.
>> [clears throat]
>> Let's take a look here.
Okay.
So, [snorts] open this up.
So, there's the one, here's the one.
And also you're seeing the other ones.
Here's a one. It's a nice little trade
here, goes up.
Okay? So, you can get the idea of what
you're looking at.
Um
there's a little one here, didn't do
anything.
Again, not all of them are going to work
out,
but the ones that do, you can get a big
move because, you know, what makes this
move so important is because as a
reversal signal,
you have the potential
to have big moves if it's if it's a true
reversal that's coming up. That's why,
you know, I'm willing to get stopped out
on a trade like this one here
if I'm going to get a reversal that
could potentially trade from the high of
the day
to the low of the day and beyond, okay?
That's the power of trading reversals.
You could get really big moves coming
out of them.
All right. So, that is the exhaustion
prints. And again, it's it's, you know,
people always say, "What's your best
What's your top trade setups?"
Well, exhaustion prints are one of them.
I talked about it in a separate video.
Um
the Orderflows Ratio and Divergence is
is another one of them. And sometimes,
you know, with order flow ratio and
divergence,
if you actually have an exhaustion print
in it,
I'm not going to say it's stronger, you
know, a stronger signal, but imagine,
you know, you've got two sort of
separate
good signals to trade
aligned at the same time. An exhaustion
print coupled
with a delta divergence
and an Orderflows Ratio, right? Those
are trades that I love to take um when I
see them. You know, you those are just
trades that have to be sort of
automatic, right? Every trader should
have
uh what I call sort of
you know, automatic trades in their
wheelhouse that their trades they're
going to take um anytime they see them.
And exhaustion print is is one of them.
And and how you trade it is soon as the
bar closes, you get long. As soon as the
next bar starts opening up and trading
in your direction, that's your sign to
get long. Okay? You don't have to wait
for any other confirmation other than
the bar to close, which basically
confirms
that you have the exhaustion print.
Okay?
So, thanks for watching this video and
I'll see you guys on the next video.